dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
先週このツイートを投稿しました新しい質問シリーズを開始しましたハッシュタグ日本
語アドバイスを使って語彙文法音声学そして学習についての一般的な質問を投稿して
ください
ツイートしてから3日が経ち
ましたさあ皆さんの出した質問読み上げて答えてみましょう
何でも聞いていいなそれともそのカテゴリーだけに対して僕は何でも大丈夫と答えた
それに対して彼は
何も聞かなかった
勉強なったようで何よりです見てて日本語の勉強になるアニメってありますか
意味を澄ます
もしくは bible black なぜ感じなぜ感じ
me
[音楽]
森の生活を一読することをお勧めます知らない感じに出くわした時にどうしたらいい
見て見ぬふりをする道元の動画を見るのやめて本当の勉強を始めたいんだけどどうし
たらいい
その必要もないさなんと月たった1000円で僕が今まで作ったすぐ後元
買い方を教えてくださいすごくいい質問だ
まずはコーターもスカ別のコインを用意してください
モテの場合はは裏の場合はいくら時間がたっても絶対にワットがの違いがわかるわけが
ないから自殺すること
無しっかやってみるか
me
もっとも効果的な文法学習方法教えてください
教科書を使うべきそれとも小説
はい文法については実は必殺技がありますまずはその文法を使った例文を作って下さい
次に自分の町にある日本人が多いバーに行くこと
最後はそのバーにいる最も綺麗な日本人女性
もしくは最もかっこいい日本人男性に話しかけて無理やりその例文を言ってみて
ください相当気まずくなるから絶対に記憶に残ります漢字の読み方を覚えるこつって
ありますか
意味がわかっていても読み方がわからないことがたくさんあります
漢字の読み方を上のコツはいあります
すでに知っている感じ
の読み方を2つ忘れること道元自分が今どんな顔をしているかわかるか
日本語の質問ではないので僕は何と返事をした
それと彼はお前には俺と同じ血が流れている
別の地を求めさまよう獣の家だ
その家はも流し尽くしたさならばなぜ生きている
tue
効かぬお
ana
me
ni